[موسيقى]
انه يوم التتويج يوم مشهود في تاريخ
بريطانيا وملكها من ابرز ملامح اليوم وضع
التاج على راس الملك والملكه واجلاسهما
على العرش بعد ان يقدم الملك عهده لشعبه
ويتلقى عهود الولاء من الرعيه وولي العهد
التتويج طقس رئيسي من طقوس يحرص النظام
الملكي البريطاني عليها ومظهر من مظاهر
الابهه والعظمه تعيد من خلاله العائله
الملكيه تجديد صورتها واظهار وحدتها
من قصر الى كاتدرائيه ويست مونستر سارى
موكب الملك تشارلز الثالث
ذهابا وايابا على خطى عشرات من اسلافه
الذين حكموا هذه البلاد قرابه الف عام
كميه الامطار التي هطلت اليوم على العاصمه
البريطانيه لندن قد تكون الاكثر في يوم
واحد منذ مطلع هذا العام لكن هذا لم يمنع
خروج عشرات الالاف من الجماهير لتقديم
التحيه لملكهم كما لم يمنع خروج اخرين
غيرهم من معارضي الملكيه
اجتمع الفريقان في ميدان ترفالقر وسط لندن
المكان الذي سمحت فيه الشرطه بمظاهره حركه
هناك وقفوا هاتفين ليس ملكي ومنادين
بالتخلي عن الملكيه واعلان بريطانيا
جمهوريه امر اختلف معه اغلب الحاضرين
لتحيه الملك
لن يحكمنا ديكتاتور طالما لدينا ملك
تمت انتقادات استهدفت الحكومه لعدم
اعلانها كلفه الاحتفال التي قدرت باكثر من
مئه مليون جنيه استرليني ولعدم الغاء
الاحتفال الذي اسقطته كل ملكيات اوروبا
منذ قرن في وقت تعتصر فيه المواطن
البريطانيه ازمه اقتصاديه طاحنه امر يراه
البعض غير مبرر بالنظر الى عائدات تدرها
العائله الملكيه على البلاد اقلها من
السياحه فيليب سمول
كلفه حفل التتويج ليست كبيره بينما
العوائد تفوقها بكثير
انتهى يوم التتويج اذا بعد ان شكل تدشينا
لعصر جديد عصر انتظره تشارلز الثالث 70
عاما هي مده حكم امه الراحله اسد الله
الصاوي الجزيره لندن